In our R Console, let's start
by loading our data set.
Don't forget to make sure you're
in the directory containing
the file wine.csv first.
We'll call our data
frame wine, and we'll
use the read.csv function to
read in the data file wine.csv.
We can look at the
structure of our data
by using the str function.
We can see that we
have a data frame
with 25 observations of
seven different variables.
Year gives the year
the wine was produced,
and it's just a
unique identifier
for each observation.
Price is the dependent variable
we're trying to predict.
And WinterRain, AGST,
HarvestRain, Age, and FrancePop
are the independent variables
we'll use to predict Price.
We can also look at the
statistical summary of our data
using the summary function.
This gives us information
about the range
of values for each
variable in our data set.
Let's now create a one-variable
linear regression equation
using AGST to predict Price.
We'll call our
regression model model1,
and we'll use the lm function,
which stands for linear model.
This is the function
we'll use whenever
we want to build a
linear regression model.
Then inside parentheses, type
Price, our dependent variable,
and then a tilde
symbol, and then
AGST, the independent variable
we'll use in this model.
Then after a comma, we
need to add data = wine
to tell the lm
function what data
set to use to build the model.
We're saving the output
of the lm function
to the variable named model1.
So when we hit Enter,
we didn't see any output
because it's been saved
to the variable model1.
Let's take a look at
the summary of model1.
The first thing we
see is a description
of the function we used
to build the model.
Then we see a summary of the
residuals or error terms.
Following that is a
description of the coefficients
of our model.
The first row corresponds
to the intercept term,
and the second row corresponds
to our independent variable,
AGST.
The Estimate column
gives estimates
of the beta values
for our model.
So here beta 0,
or the coefficient
for the intercept term,
is estimated to be -3.4.
And beta 1, or the coefficient
for our independent variable,
is estimated to be 0.635.
There's additional
information in this table
that we'll discuss
in the next video.
Towards the bottom
of the output,
you can see Multiple
R-squared, 0.435,
which is the R-squared
value that we
discussed in the previous video.
Beside it is a number
labeled Adjusted R-squared.
In this case, it's 0.41.
This number adjusts
the R-squared value
to account for the number of
independent variables used
relative to the
number of data points.
Multiple R-squared
will always increase
if you add more
independent variables.
But Adjusted R-squared
will decrease
if you add an
independent variable that
doesn't help the model.
This is a good way to determine
if an additional variable
should even be
included in the model.
We'll also discuss
other ways to select
important independent
variables in the next video.
Let's also compute the sum
of squared errors, or SSE,
for our model.
Our residuals, or error terms,
are stored in the vector
model1$residuals.
By hitting Enter, we can see the
values of all of our residuals.
We can compute the Sum of
Squared Errors, or SSE,
by taking the
sum(model1$residuals^2).
If we type SSE and
hit Enter, we can
see that our sum of
squared errors is 5.73.
Now let's add another
variable to our regression
model, HarvestRain.
We'll call our new model model2.
And again, we'll use the lm
function to predict Price,
but this time using
AGST and HarvestRain.
When you want to use more
than one independent variable,
you can just separate them with
a plus sign like we did here.
Then we again need to
indicate that the data that
should be used is wine.
Let's take a look at the
summary of our new model
using the summary function.
We have a third row in
our Coefficients table
now corresponding
to HarvestRain.
The coefficient estimate for
this new independent variable
is negative 0.00457.
And if you look at the R-squared
near the bottom of the output,
you can see that this variable
really helped our model.
Our Multiple R-squared
and Adjusted R-squared
both increased significantly
compared to the previous model.
This indicates that this
new model is probably
better than the previous model.
Let's now also compute
the sum of squared errors
for this new model.
So SSE equals, and then
sum(model2$residuals^2).
If we type SSE, we can see
that the sum of squared errors
for model2 is
2.97, which is much
better than the sum of
squared errors for model1.
Now let's build a
third model, this time
with all of our
independent variables.
We'll call this one model3.
And again, use the lm function
to predict Price using AGST
and HarvestRain and WinterRain
and Age and FrancePop.
Again, we need to
tell the lm function
to use the data set wine.
Let's take a look at
the summary of model3.
Now the Coefficients table has
six rows, one for the intercept
and one for each of the
five independent variables.
If we look at the
bottom of the output,
we can again see that the
Multiple R-squared and Adjusted
R-squared have both increased.
Let's now compute the
sum of squared errors
for this new model.
SSE equals the
sum(model3$residuals^2).
And if we type SSE, we can see
that the sum of squared errors
for model3 is 1.7, even
better than before.
In the next video,
we'll determine
if we should keep all of these
variables in our final model.